the big question dominating french
politics can the far right really win
after five years of president macron
french voters are deciding his future at
the ballot box
he won the highest share of the vote in
this first round but it's tight the full
verdict is still two weeks away and a
second term for the country's youngest
ever premiere appears vulnerable
[Applause]
at this decisive moment for the future
of the nation nothing must be as it was
before
i would like to take the hand of
everyone who would like to work for
france to join me i'm ready to invent
something new
on the other side of paris president
macron has the same rival once again
as marine le pen arrived i asked if she
was feeling confident
a simple nod said it all
this is the far-right leaders third and
final attempt at the french presidency
and if you go by the polls she's never
got as close as this
marine le pen has presented a softer
more unifying image of herself in this
campaign
in this campaign i decided not to be
partisan to be at the service of all and
to directly address you
i will carry on doing so so the day
after the second round not to exclude
anyone to be the president for all the
french people
le pen's decision to focus on the cost
of living was a smart choice and won her
a broader church of voters speaking less
on immigration and islam has helped to
detoxify her brand
critics say she's changed her style but
not her far right values but this time
marine le pen is far more palatable to
many voters and those voters are far
less predictable
even marine le pen's past praise for
vladimir putin didn't dent her support
during a horrifying war in ukraine
one of her mps is confident there will
be a president le pen in two weeks time
everybody from the right or from the
left are most welcome to join the big
reunion that marine le pen will create
for france
france will now look to voting between
macron and le pen normally parties form
a pact to vote together in round two
against the far right but this time it
feels like the rule book's been ripped
up
it's complicated
[Music]
[Music]
anything can happen and nobody thought
brexit would happen
well to people of my generation really
didn't think it would happen and it has
nobody thought trump would come into
power and he did so i think we have to
consider that it's always an option
the overall impression is french people
are looking for a change but that change
could give vladimir putin a perceived
ally in the elysee palace
france feels in unchartered election
territory
sally lockwood sky news paris